CBS News medical contributor dr. David
agus joins us now with more on the
corona virus pandemic doctor good
morning to you what is most concerning
to you about the recent surge of cases
in some of these states and do you see
more states at this point now slowing
down they're reopening Jeff yeah it's a
scary time I mean we're certainly seeing
rising number in many pockets of the
country it's predominantly younger
individuals the problem is they then
come home and spread to their parents
their grandparents their neighbors etc
and so every person who has the virus
isn't spreading it to more than one
person so when numbers are going up
numbers will keep going up and in a much
more alarming rate over time
doctor hey it's Michelle here while
cases are up in certain areas the the
rates of new deaths are down with the
correlation there hey Michelle you know
the the the problem of this Rises that
were the good of this rise is that a
younger generation younger generations
classically can get the virus can be
mildly symptomatic but are not going to
be hospitalized in a lower death rate so
that's why we're seeing those numbers
and also there's also a delayed many
times on the death rate the problem is
again those younger people can spread to
others so unless we intervene unless we
start to do social distancing contact
tracing and wearing masks it's not going
to change doctor I guess it's Dana now
and you just mentioned that younger
generation give us some sense we're
seeing the data that has a lot of these
new cases being from the younger
generation what does that mean well you
know in ruel inning one we knew the
rules right stay at home we all did that
and we did great inning number two is
well the rules are different all over
the place it's not clear what is right
and that younger generation especially
is saying hey forget it I'm just going
out I'm going back to my normal I can't
stay in anymore and so I'm going out and
I'm not gonna listen to wearing a mask
in social distancing they're catching
the virus and spreading to others you
know it's very frustrating from a public
health side it's very frustrating to the
citizens who are doing the right
because the virus is spreading in many
pockets of the country at a tremendous
rate you talk about them going out more
and the idea of wearing a mask
regardless if you are out more as people
are now it's something you and I emailed
about this week if you're out and around
a group of people or if you are
traveling how long should you wait after
that to get tested to potentially I
guess get the best result well I think
the period of exposure is exactly what
you're asking and so when you're exposed
there's a period where you could get the
virus anywhere from 2 to 14 days later
in general it's in that first week but
it depends how much of the virus you
were exposed to people exposed to we
think to a lower level of virus many
times it can take 10 or 12 days before
they are symptomatic and before you can
test positive so it's a longer period
which is why we had that two week stay
at home period the two week quarantine
in many countries when you go there or
many cities or in the state of Hawaii
it's because of that 2 to 14 day window
you know yeah I saw some of the numbers
up there we talked about the corona
virus test and then the antibody test
and I think we talked about this a lot a
couple weeks ago but are there any new
indications with some of the antibody
tests that mean we may know more from
them or are we still in the same place
that we've been when you get a virus
there are two ways you fight it one is
making antibodies the second is t-cells
well when you measure one half of it it
tells you a piece of the story and most
of the tests on the market measure all
of your antibodies to coronavirus
including prior ones they don't measure
ones to the spike protein that block the
virus from getting in what we call
neutralizing antibodies so the antibody
tests are a piece to the puzzle but they
do not show you immunity they show you
prior exposure and it's really important
because we don't know how long immunity
will last we don't yet have the ability
to quantify immunity my hope is science
will catch up and we'll be able to do
that because that's gonna be critically
important as we go forward and
especially as we look at opening schools
and workplaces open more is defined who
is immune before we get to vaccine and
we can make everybody immune to this
virus exactly what I was thinking dr.
David agus thank you so much